qu'est-ce que vous attendez de ce débat
d'entre eux entre les deux candidats
bien ce que tous les Français attendent
c'est-à-dire la confrontation entre deux
projets
de manière de voir l'avenir de notre
pays et pour que chacun soit éclairé et
puis se décider ce qui est manuel Macron
et pas un peu sous pression il a un
bilan à défendre il a géré beaucoup de
crises il a une campagne très rapide
finalement c'est celui qui a le plus à
perdre
sous pression je ne crois pas cela
je crois que chacun est concentré
j'imagine en tout cas pour
pouvoir exprimer son son point de vue le
confronté et j'espère que les arguments
déjà et des autres seront mis sur la
table pour que tous ceux qui vont
regarder ce débats puisque se faire une
idée si jamais leur idée n'était pas
déjà faite quel est l'enjeu vis-à-vis de
son adversaire Marine Le Pen sur quel
point il faut appuyer
je ne suis pas au débat c'est le
président qui verra bien comment il
convient qu'il débattent il y a un enjeu
de clarté vis-à-vis de son programme
je crois que tout ce qui peut être
explicité pour les gens ou pour les
autres
sera utile et s'agissant de Marine Le
Pen ce sera bien que ce qu'elle propose
soit démasqué parce que sous des dehors
bon as en vérité elle cache des
positions extrêmement radicales qui sont
à l'inverse des valeurs et de ceux qui
fait que nous sommes français merci
monsieur
[Musique]